as we said in our opening monologue
corrupt deep state actors may have
trouble sleeping tonight after these
reports anti-trump dossier author
Christopher Steele sat down from 15
hours worth of interviews with the DOJ
is inspector general here to react to
all the breaking news tonight and more
president Trump's attorney Rudy Giuliani
is was mister mister mayor so all this
news he gives 15 hours of testimony now
finally others decided last minute that
they want to talk to Horowitz and then
we learn about general Flynn I you're a
prosecutor I don't like this practice
you get a get-out-of-jail-free card if
you just say what we tell you to say
that's a Weissman special which mullah
tolerated and you know Moe it should
never have been appointed whatever he
was independent counsel or serial
counsel or right asleep counsel he did
the same thing in the Whitey Bulger case
I mean a federal judge named nancy
gertner a classmate of the Clintons said
that his handling of that whole thing
was a serious problem for the FBI and it
was chilling in the way he covered up
for a couple of FBI rats who actually
did the murders and people spent 40
years in prison for four murders that
they didn't commit other people had
committed them and the FBI knew all
along and I'm kind of like not making
this up the US Attorney in Connecticut
knows this case better than I did he
uncovered it but so I mean Mulla Mulla
Mulla is a guy who has tolerated this
kind of incompetent unethical
over-the-top behavior in defense of the
institution I don't know what his makeup
is but you know I I didn't really focus
on all this until I got involved in this
case or that I was sure I shocked it the
way they handled this case I mean
they're totally out of control you can't
offer a get-out-of-jail-free card and
then feed people what you want on this
you know when you can't put a man like
man afford in solitary confinement for
seven months and bring him in 13 times
like Weissman did tell them what to say
and when he tells you it's not true send
them back to solitary confinement and
bring them out in four more days unless
you're trying to suborn perjury well you
don't give a damn if it's the morning
perjury and you can't do what he did to
Corsi I got the documents on that they
got cut ready
in that and that one we had to go to the
Justice Department to get them slapped
across the face for being a bunch of
unethical disgraceful prosecutors which
is what they are and all this lionizing
of Muller is disgraceful and that's what
you're going to find out these guys are
the guys that need to be investigated
well we've been investigating the
investigators we're learning all awful
lot that I don't like look I want truth
and justice but you can't say sing or
compose so we're gonna put you in jail
say what we want or we'll put you in
jail what only if you have the liberal
media which makes you into some kind of
a king for doing that and a prince when
in fact this is like this this is the
scourge of people who are civil
libertarians prosecutors like this
that's why you got a guy like like Alan
Dershowitz in shock that these people
are being lionized like this
how does Muller justify fairer
investigations you and I both know that
that's usually fill out the form fine
see you later
or or loan applications or taxi
medallions all of which he and taxes
from you know a decade gone by and
ignore steals dirty dossier that the
other candidate that was used to spy on
a campaign he was a hit man he didn't
care for that he didn't he wasn't he
wasn't hired Weissman if he cared about
the truth would he he wouldn't have
hired Jeanne ray the council to to
Clinton's are the Clinton Foundation
right next to you because these people
died I would advise people like that
they wouldn't see the inside of my US
Attorney's Office I did kick them out I
mean when he did that I said to myself
what the heck is wrong with him well
then I figured out what's wrong with him
he's basically asleep and the rear and
the reality the reality is that this was
a pot from the very beginning to frame
Trump that's what you're gonna find out
it could rather complex it has a whole
counterintelligence spin to it and it's
gonna get worse and worse and worse and
why is this the first time somebody sat
down would steal for fifteen hours Comey
never did it it was unverified hey
you're the director of the FBI you're
supposed to verify jerk you're supposed
to verify don't tell me you can't verify
man I'd have thrown him out of the
office if I were the
general you didn't you come to me it's
the president and you tell me the thing
is unverified and you've had it for four
months and you haven't bothered to
verify it it would find out it for scrap
he signed off in October 2016
he had four months to verify it months
later he said it's unverified walking
into the President of the United States
or the president of like the United
States and saying it's unverified
unverified you had four months to verify
it and you run the most competent
effective law enforcement agency in the
world or at least you claim you do and
you ruined it pal because they're all
ashamed of you and they should be
ashamed of Muller you look back on
mullahs record now with an eye of what
he was doing you look at that ho whitey
bulger thing and you say wow this was
predictable what do you predict on
Wednesday because I think when Jim
Jordan and Doug Collins and Matt gates
and a few others asked these questions
how did you investigate these things but
not the dirty dossier from Russia that
was used to really influence the
election and used to spy on the
opposition party how to do the
investigation of the first place when
you lead agent Peter struck had done the
original investigation and concluded
there with no evidence of collusion and
he text he texted it to his girlfriend
there's no there there he didn't tell
you there's no there there he told his
girlfriend but not you
why because you don't show up in the
office because you're behind an Iron
Curtain I saw the guy one time in a year
and a half I heard him speak for an hour
and a half one time I called him The
Wizard of Oz because he was behind the
curtain and would be we're going to tape
it to Bob we're going to pick this to
Bob well Bob is in charge pal when I was
the US Attorney I was in charge I was in
charge of the Commission case I was in
charge of the case against boesky I was
in charge not not a bunch of assistants
sure they helped a lot but I was the guy
on the line and I wasn't behind some
Iron Curtain or some some curtain like
it well he's going to be out of the
curtain and we're gonna find out answers
and let's see if Bob can answer them I
think he's gonna have a tough time
Wednesday it's not gonna go the way the
media thinks mr. mayor could decide I
doubt it and you know be very
interesting to see if he does another
stuff
and bundling like he did for his nine
minutes Attorney General Bart's my
theory bailed him out with that joint
statement we'll see I think he builds a
good guy and a great a great Attorney
General so I'm not gonna criticize bill
he's going right job I'm just saying I
sensed he didn't but tried to throw him
a lifeline you know Wow Matt no you
didn't take it
guess not all right Marilee Bertie
Juliette just tell us how you really
think we will always want to know